okay everyone today I've got another
exam video for you this time
it's an astrophysics exam and it's from
MIT so this is a real exam paper from
their website and even better than usual
this exam paper contains the full worked
solutions to the content so I think that
would be really helpful I'll go through
it I'll show you what you can expect
from an astrophysics exam like what the
kinds of questions are and what answers
look like in this subject so on some of
my other exam videos a few people in the
comments seem a bit salty that the
content I cover is not that hard or it's
too easy I'm showing you exams that are
what you can definitely expect to see if
you major in one of these courses so
something that's an undergrad first
second or third year something like that
I haven't been showing you guys graduate
content
so there's definitely harder things and
what I'm going to show but I think the
things that are in these exams are
representative of what you can expect so
let's have a look in this exam we've got
eight questions and it looks like we're
expected to attempt all of them it's a
closed book exam but it says you may use
two pages of notes usually this means
that before you come in you can write up
two pages of handwritten notes that
you're allowed to have with you and
that's usually where you're just going
to write some formulas so let's have a
look first we've got a sheet of
constants that's going to be helpful
it's good because you don't have to
memorize numbers like this you never
have to you can get through your whole
degree without knowing with the speed of
light but you use it so often that it's
probably ingrained in your brain anyway
first problem is looks like it's about
stellar astrophysics we've got a neutron
star is an orbit around a normal star
matter is flowing from the normal star
into the collapsed star at a certain
rate and then we'll just ask to find
some information about this like
calculating the luminosity of the
neutron star and also computing the
temperature to work out both of these
you can
see the solution it's actually
reasonably simple once you find an
equation that you know is relevant so
we've got a couple of equations here
it's really just a matter of rearranging
it putting in the constants putting in
the relevant numbers from the question
it's not too hard and in fact I think
most of the maths involved in
astrophysics at least is what I'm going
to show you in this paper it's not very
advanced maths it's mostly algebra
mostly rearranging equations all right
so our second question about a similar
topic we're asked to find a mass of a
star and yet similar sort of thing
rearranging the formula you might see
here that we have these symbols M with a
little circle in it that means solar
mass so you're calculating the mass of a
star in terms of solar masses that's the
mass of our Sun it's a nice little
constant that we can use to simplify
from problems and even get a intuitive
understanding of how big some of these
stars are okay this problem we have HR
diagrams those are sprung rustle
diagrams and you will see these all the
time if you study astrophysics they
essentially tell you about the life
cycle of stars you can plot the apparent
visual magnitude so how bright a star
looks against things like its
temperature and you can see essentially
the evolution of a star over time what
happens to it as it burns through its
mass as it changes in brightness over
its lifespan and these plots are
essentially a bunch of stars plotted
based on those factors so the questions
here are deducing things from the
hertzsprung-russell diagram again I
don't think this is too complicated
your your looking at the diagrams and by
the time you reach the exam you should
know how to read them over here we're
coming into these short answers part of
the exams are a few small shorter
questions to answer
we've got a dimensional analysis problem
so looking at units and making sure that
you understand those and that they make
sense to you and then we've got some
explained type questions these will be
your favorite if you don't like to
rearrange equations and do the math you
can just explain a concept that you're
asked to here we're talking about what
is 21 centimeter radiation and what can
we learn by studying it some more short
problems a couple more explanations and
plugging something into a formula really
we were asked about the cosmic microwave
background radiation and asked to talk
about three effects that dust has on
starlight all right we've got another
question about stars this time it's
variable stars that are changing in
brightness and then were asked about
standard candles which are away in
astrophysics to estimate distances
between objects because these so called
standard candles are objects that you
kind of well you know they have a
constant brightness and you know the
distance to them so you can use that to
map out the distances to other places
this problem here is about galaxies now
it kind of looks a bit intimidating
you've got a very big write-up and then
a lot of math down here but actually
these are just like four short questions
that all relate to the same topic so
once you get one should be a bit of a
flow-on effect and the others shouldn't
be too hard
here we've got some spectra this is also
pretty typical of astrophysics a lot of
what you're doing is taking light from
stars getting spectra of it so that you
can find out something about the
chemical composition of the star or the
object and knowing how to read spectra
is pretty important so here we have some
and a few of these questions here
involved basically reading off peaks in
wavelength from these graphs so like the
first question is find a redshift which
involves looking at the shift in
wavelengths between these plots
and then I think a few other sort of
short questions there again these
formula are probably stuff that you've
written down on your little cheat sheet
or your a sheet of paper you're allowed
to bring in if it's a closed book exam
and time entirely then you'll probably
be given these relevant formula you need
and then in the exam it will be more a
matter of picking the right one off the
formula sheet exams are not supposed to
be too hard like things like looking at
a formula sheet and finding the right
formula are things that you should be
able to do if you've paid attention in
the course and I think that's all this
exam is trying to do is trying to show
that you paid attention and you
understand the concepts that have been
talked about it doesn't necessarily mean
you have a deep understanding of the
physics in terms of having a lot of your
own independent thoughts behind it which
I've spoken about before is something I
don't really like about university
courses but exams I guess not the place
to be testing that because it is quite a
stressful environment our last question
here is what about the recession
velocity of galaxies as a function of
distance now this question actually
comes I think more into the
classification of cosmology which is
really cool so you're talking
essentially about the expansion rate of
the universe because you're being asked
to estimate the Hubble constant from
this information Part B is using the
Hubble constant to estimate the age of
the universe and then we're asked a
question relating to Newtonian cosmology
to derive a more exact relation between
the Hubble constant and the current age
of the universe so I think there's a few
cool cosmology questions there the link
to this exam is in the description so I
encourage you if you're curious to
download it and have a read through
yourself and actually read through some
the solutions you can go and paste then
and it's probably a lot easier to read I
enjoy making these and let me know if
you have any ideas for future ones and
thanks for watching